in spite of being illegal under
international law lower parliamentary
officials in Russia unanimously approve
the annexation of four Ukrainian regions
another fact all but being ignored by
Russia that it doesn't have total
control of all the areas it now claims
as Russian territory
Ukraine continues to battle for every
inch of its eastern Ridge including the
Donetsk oblast Russia's defense Ministry
acknowledged a Ukrainian tank unit
pushed through the Russian lines in part
of the kierson region an aggressive
counter-offensive has resulted in the
liberation of several cities such as
izum harkiv and just recently Limon a
Papito has been organized today in an
attempt to deny the obvious
that the aggressive and adventurist
regime in Russia is heading to its
imminent defeat
this 75 year old Soviet Army veteran is
one of many who has taken part in public
acts of defiance while under Russian
occupation he eventually left kirsaw
knowing he was an easy target
what I was most afraid of was not the
Orcs but the local collaborators Russia
claiming the four regions as its own
will make it even harder for ukrainians
to flee to safer cities the U.S
ambassador to the U.N called on the
security Council to compel Russia to
withdraw its troops and introduced a
resolution to not acknowledge the recent
Russian land grab they changed nothing
about the status and borders of Ukraine
Russia voted against the resolution
China Gabon India and Brazil all
abstained
Crystal gomancing Global News London